Європейське видання EUobserver 4 січня оприлюднило аудіозапис,
на якому начебто посадові особи КДБ Білорусі обговорюють усунення критиків режиму Лукашенка, зокрема і журналіста Павла Шеремета.
Аудіофайл надав Ігор Макар - колишній співробітник білоруського антитерористичного спецпідрозділу "Алмаз".
Всі люди, яких обговорюють на цих записах, живі, окрім журналіста Павла Шеремета.
Шеремет загинув у 2016 році у Києві, внаслідок підриву авто.
Макар впевнений, що за цим стоять білоруські спецслужби,
бо на записі в деталях обговорюють план з підривом автівки.
Ігор Макар працював у спецпідрозділі "Алмаз". У 2003-му звільнився за власним бажанням
і почав співпрацювати з політиком Олександром Козуліним, який балотувався в президенти Білорусі у 2006-му році.
У виборчому штабі Козуліна Макар відповідав за безпеку. Але якраз напередодні виборів
у 2006 році через загрози життю виїхав до однієї з країн Євросоюзу.
За словами Макара, аудіозапис потрапив до нього у 2012 році від анонімних джерел з Комітету держбезпеки Білорусі,
і ще тоді він передав інформацію американським спецслужбам.
Ігор Макар каже, що не знає, чи попередили тоді Павла Шеремета про загрозу його життю.
Я вважаю, що Павло володів дуже серйозною інформацією про те,
що стосувалося безвісти зниклих політиків у 1999 і 2000-му роках.
Він серйозно займався даною темою.
Причому під час виборів вийшла книга Олега Алкаєва "Розстрільна команда",
і це серйозно понизило рейтинг Лукашенко.
Думаю, саме через це Лукашенко розпорядився фізично усунути Шеремета.
Коли стало відомо про загибель Шеремета в 2016 році,
чи повідомили Ви про наявність цього аудіозапису українським спецслужбам?
Ні, у мене тоді не було контакту з украинською владою або спецслужбами.
Також для того, аби в 2016 році оприлюднити цей запис,
мені довелося б розмовляти з людьми, яким після цього могла б загрожувати небезпека.
Тобто, я одразу цей запис оприлюднити не зміг би.
Після загибелі Шеремета Ви взагалі давали комусь цю запис?
Ні, ніколи й нікому не давав.
Ігор Макар вважає, що обрав правильний час для оприлюднення записів,
адже вся Білорусь повстала проти режиму і його допомога була потрібна.
Також він додав, що "приблизно в грудні" 2020 року"
передав записи українським правоохоронцям і готовий дати свідчення в Генпрокуратурі України.
Глава МВС України Аресен Аваков вже анонсував можливі слідчі дії в Європі
вже у січні в зв'язку з отриманими ним новими матеріалами.